ah Brazil the beautiful sunkissed home
of Pele hairless genitalia and the
world's largest Jared Leto statue to
show my dedication to the legions of
Brazilian Deadpool fans
I've spent up to 20 minutes on Google
Translate as well as countless hours
watching telenovelas to teach me
everything about your official language
that's right but I see you this sexy red
spandex task learn to speak Portuguese
all right
hopefully I get the accent right here
goes the second across Peninsula same
pronouced own RSS so annoying heritage
SEO nuna comic-con Brazil voman
Darmstadt o odorous mas o menos
Leonardo's producer Kapoor nukemama
Bella Terra Bella as a guru she assented
Elish Volgin sapelo Co Co Co Co Masha
Kiran comic CEO Jeffrey Suraj
Emil a party a cave I say completamente
gratis innovate Costa nada assassin
Aaron contrato Dispenza
se prepara para guardar drape a chichi
Lubeck Oh Michelle Falacci of science
porque Hamada season 5 cocoon gossip
resembling a mo kamo Mo Kio temple anima
Mundi data Eden Samba Peled own Familia
specific Comanche swamp main cannon
elephant poo taka Fatima al Ghul you
Peloso pi ish it's a my Appa due to this
focus on motherless
prison suggests a premiere of a so
Ultima I want Visayan Mizuki be don't
tap another Enya you just got some
Angelica look me straighten the nipples
and tell me I didn't just nail that now
what are you waiting for
go to the website below to reserve your
spot and you're sure to be the talk of
South Paulo space is limited so best
hurry because I think we can all agree
there's nothing like a wild day or night
in Brazil to make a special memory that
you'll cherish forever
just ask the 2016 US men's swimming team
they'll probably make some [ __ ] up
hey everybody after spending a clear
twenty minutes on Google train
lay dead pool drops this teaser before
Brazil comic-con if you have no idea
what this is for or what he's talking
about Brazil comic-con is this weekend
and they're basically sending Deadpool
tattoo artists to give people free
tattoos but you may have detected that
his Portuguese voice is the Vanessa
character it's Morena Baccarin speaking
in portuguese slowly trolling everyone
as if Deadpool wrote a bunch of jokes
for her to read out loud and she didn't
read what he wrote before she started
speaking it so just winds up being this
funny explainer for how you can get all
this free stuff at Brazil Comic Con
while at the same time dropping a couple
of funny Easter eggs but if you aren't
finding me for the first time we'll be
doing all kinds of Deadpool comic-book
stuff during December so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and I'll
just go ahead and do a new round of the
IMAX ticket giveaway at the end of this
- but the important thing first this is
actually a real thing they're doing this
for free for fans it's sort of like a
first-come first-served situation but
you have to sign a health waiver like
they make the joke about rolling the
hepatitis dice there's a little bit of
fine print but it's just something funny
that they're doing for the fans there's
some fun engagement so I would say that
they'd be dropping more footage this
weekend for Brazil Comic Con they might
air a special teaser while they're down
there but I think that this is sort of
their promotion for that week so if we
see more Deadpool to footage it's
probably going to drop later this month
in the some weird teaser form like they
did during the 12 days of Deadpool a
couple years ago but even if you don't
read Portuguese you probably detected
all the Easter eggs in the subtitles so
like he says letting their ink build
needles dance across her body like
Shakira in a soda commercial she
actually did a Pepsi commercial a long
time ago
[Music]
one of the tattoos is just the Deadpool
loved symbol he says love for his right
hand everybody knows what that means
one of the tattoos is for family
especially for your mom she makes a
wonderful breakfast implying the
Deadpool spent the night with your mom
last night so everybody just double
check on that
the pride symbol for your country and
its leading export supermodels there are
a lot of amazing Brazilian supermodels
the Deadpool prison tattoo that number
on that is actually for his original
comic book it's New Mutants number 98 in
February 1991 so that's what that number
means nm 98 o 291 apparently you get the
best of cuddles inside prison look him
straight in the nipples he totally
nailed that you may have forgotten about
the u.s. men's swim team but the joke
that he makes about the 2016 Olympics is
when Ryan Lochte got arrested for
falsely saying that he and a bunch of
other people got robbed at gunpoint it
turned out to be totally false there was
this gas station video that they
released he got in a ton of trouble he
lost all of his sponsors it was this big
disgrace he's been climbing out of the
hole ever since so it was just a small
group of people from the US men's swim
team showing just how dumb they were so
let me know what you guys think about
this even if you're not going to Brazil
comic-con what do you think about them
doing fan engagement stuff like this I
feel like they do a better job of
marketing this movie than most movies do
like we'll see what they do for infinity
war obviously they'll have some crazy
roll out because it's Marvel Studios
10th anniversary and I'm sure if that
Fox deal goes through with Fox and
Marvel sharing their characters or
Disney buying part of Fox
they'll probably release some epic
Deadpool teaser where he just rails
against Mickey Mouse for trying to water
him down or some funny thing like that
for those of you wondering though this
is actually a pretty big deal if Disney
does buy Fox and they get the rights to
the Deadpool character what will
probably happen is that it'll just allow
him to exist on his own as a separate
brand from everything else that's going
on because part of the success of the
character has been in the way that
they've used him so I don't think
they're gonna want to mess with that
Kevin Feige is actually a huge fan of
the
Deadpool character meaning that if they
got those characters he'd be in charge
of what they did with Deadpool so I
don't think that he's gonna mess with
that anytime soon so even if you're
worried about Disney doing bad things
with the Fox characters if Marvel gets
them back just trust Kevin Feige as long
as you trust his judgment everything
will be fine
he doesn't have to serve any crazy CEO
anymore i Karl motor doesn't control his
characters he does whatever he wants to
with them he reports to alan horne
disney at the top i feel like there's so
many other characters that they could
put in the Marvel Universe before they
go to Deadpool they might try to do
something real a bunny with the
character but I don't think they're
gonna try and shoe horn him into the
tone of what the current Marvel movies
are doing I think they'll just let him
do his own thing but at the end of the
day that just depends on whether or not
the deal actually goes through I've just
seen a lot of people asking me more and
more because talks renewed in the last
couple of weeks and supposedly the deal
makers at Fox are favoring a deal with
Disney over other suitors because there
are other people that want to buy their
assets so like comcast could wind up
buying Foggs
so nothing is a done deal we'll find out
more by the end of the year if there's
any big developments I will do a video
about it
but for the time being all the Fox
Marvel movies that you've heard about in
the last year there'll be no messing
with those movies nothing would really
change right away I talked a little bit
about Galactus maybe in the Marvel
cosmic movies but that's like a
completely separate thing so just
imagine Marvel phase for them slowly
integrating Fox characters but we can
talk about that in a separate video but
there is a new round of that imax ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video congratulations to the winner
from my last Marvel video rapper Z
please private message me so I can get
your contact details click here for that
last big Deadpool a teaser trailer and
you can click here for my hope old
Buster video they
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight